how about a story out of New York an  update on that Congressman elect George  Santos so earlier this week we told you  about a New York Times article that  raises questions about the 34 year old  Republicans college credentials and  career on Wall Street well now Mr Santos  is accused of possibly misleading voters  about having Jewish ancestry his  campaign website says his grandparents  fled Jewish persecution in Ukraine  settled in Belgium and again fled  persecution during World War II the  Jewish publication the forward  investigated and found his mother's  parents were born in Brazil not in  Ukraine or in Belgium Santos's  Representatives have not responded to  requests for comment he should come out  and say something there are so many  things yes he seems to have been very  fluid with the truth on many different  areas of his life I like that word yeah  that's not good so we'll see